hello and welcome to the session on
installing tensorflow my name is Mohan
and I am going to take you through the
process of setting up the tensor flow
development environment as some of you
may be aware it's not that easy to set
up the tensor flow environment there are
several components there are several
possibilities for example you can set up
on Windows you can sit upon
Ubuntu no Ubuntu has multiple versions
which version to use and then you have
Python which release of Python to use
whether to do a pip install whether to
do install using anaconda and how do you
then link it up with Jupiter notebook
these are multiple possibilities and it
takes up a lot of time to try all of
these so what I'm going to do is show
you a tried and tested method of setting
up the tensorflow environment and this
will have primarily those who are
starting with tensorflow so that they
don't have to waste so much time on
setting up the environment in
experimenting with the insulation and
setting up of the environment now what
we are going to do is I will show you a
method by which you you know it is a
tried and tested method and of course
tensorflow home page has a install page
and it shows you some ways to install
but again the challenge is the same
there are multiple versions multiple
methods shown there so it's highly
confusing for somebody who is new as to
decide which one which path to take so
in today's session what we are going to
do is we will setup tensorflow
on Ubuntu and I'm going to show you in a
VirtualBox but then if you are using a
laptop open to install you can
straightaway use the same method however
we need to keep one thing in mind that
the various releases and versions of
Ubuntu Python tensorflow not all of them
are compatible with each other so these
versions and releases need to be very
specific so I will tell you which is the
and releases of what combination is best
suited for you to get started and later
on of course you can then experiment
with other possibilities and other
releases and so on once you get familiar
with tensor flow to start with I would
also like to mention that it is a good
idea to install or start with Ubuntu
environment or a Linux any other Linux
also but here we will focus on Ubuntu
rather than Windows so for those who are
already let's say using a Windows system
the question may arise what do we do but
there is a easy option as you can see
I'm actually using a VirtualBox
so you need to install VirtualBox let me
just show you so this is the VirtualBox
Oracle VM VirtualBox and there are tons
of videos on YouTube how to install
VirtualBox and how to create one to
image I think we will not spend time on
that but if you are using Windows and my
preference would be to set up a virtual
box and set up your environment in
ubuntu image so we will start by
assuming that you have an Ubuntu
environment especially it release 14.04
LTS there are multiple one two versions
and again we will not try to get the
latest and the greatest versions latest
and greatest releases but the focus here
is to take the releases and versions
which are working and where you will not
the waste time so the setup process will
be smooth if you stick to these releases
you can of course experiment later on
with other versions and try out but here
we will be working with Ubuntu 1404 LTS
and we will use Python 3.4 and we will
use tensorflow 1.5 this is a tried and
tested combination and I would also
recommend that you use the same if you
want a smooth start and so let's get
started with that let me login to my
open the system okay so we have the
Ubuntu system running here now if you go
to tensorflow dot
work there is a page which mentions how
to install tensorflow and as you can see
there are multiple possibilities you
have kuben do you have Windows and Mac
OS and so on and so forth and if you go
to one do for example further you will
get multiple options whether you want
CPU or GPU and whether you want to do
pip install or using a virtual native
pair virtually and we and a corner and
so on and so forth so if all these
options are very complicated or rather
very confusing I would say not
complicated depending on whether your
expert or of course I am talking about
beginners here but if you click on some
of these options they may look very easy
so for example if we go back and if you
select for example native pip it may
appear like oh this is just you know one
single or two steps and that's about it
everything gets installed you see here
it should be just one step install if
you say be pre-installed that's a floor
and everything gets installed
unfortunately it doesn't work that way
so it's not as easy as so don't get kind
of fooled by the simplicity of the of
the documentation here again it's not
their fault because of the multiple
combinations of releases and so on and
so forth it is not that easy so what we
will do is we will take a slightly
roundabout method which is using
anaconda which has a few more steps but
you're sure that this is going to work
so that is what we are going to do and
that's what I am going to show you so
what are the steps involved of course I
will not go exactly by what they have
mentioned here as I said I will show you
the steps which are again sure shot to
work whereas here again if you follow
just this document there will be some
variations which they have kind of not
and document it so that's the reason I
will show you the steps separately all
right so these are the main four steps
you need to download and install
anaconda and then create a virtual
environment with Python and the release
as I mentioned is Python 3.4 and we will
install tensorflow
version 1.5 and then we will install and
configure Jupiter which will be our
development
all right so let's get started this is
our Ubuntu and let's get a terminal
started here and okay
yes so alright so we start at the
terminal and then what we'll also do is
we'll go to the anaconda website because
we need to install anaconda we need to
download and install anaconda
so for that you need to go to the
anaconda website so get just open a
browser and Google website
so this is the site anaconda dot o-r-g
click on this link and it will take you
to the and condor website you don't have
to sign up or anything like that just
look for the download anaconda so just
click on that it will take you to the
download pages and it automatically
recognizes that you are on Ubuntu so it
will show you the links to download
alright so as you can see it has
recognized that you are on a line on
some operating system so you can just
click on this download and it will start
the download there are two versions of
course Python with Python 3.6 and 2.7 I
recommend you start with Python 3.6 now
I just want to clarify that we will be
actually using Python 3.4 this is just
for the initial installation but
subsequently when we set up the virtual
environment you will see there is one
more step where we set up the virtual
environment there we will actually be
using Python 3.4 so just that you are
not confused alright so start at the
download we just say no thanks for this
and it's downloading while it is
downloading you can click on this link
saying how to install anaconda
so there are a couple of steps mentioned
there that we will be using so let me
just in the meanwhile click on this for
some reason the network is a little slow
so it's taking time alright so once the
download is done we will be using the
options that are mentioned here now the
first step of course is we are already
doing the first step which is
downloading the Installer for Linux
the second step is not mandatory so it's
an optional step most often you can
actually skip that and third step is
what we are going to do and since we are
using at this point we are using Python
3.6 we should use this command so
basically the terminal we have opened
here is is to use or to run this command
that's the reason I open this however
make sure that the download is complete
before you run this command
so we'll just wait for a couple of
minutes and we'll come back once the
download is done all right so as you can
see the download is done this is a
fairly large file so if you are on a
slow internet or low Internet bandwidth
then it might take quite a while it's
about 578 MB and so this is the file now
what you need to do is you need to go
back to this installation steps and let
me minimize this and yeah so this is the
command that you need to run so you can
just directly copy and paste this
command from here okay so to copy right
mask-like
now it will ask you a bunch of questions
as documented here so most of them you
need to just say enter or yes and that's
about it except for the last step I will
just show you what I mean and here you
need to do press ENTER multiple times
just to make sure you agree to all these
agreement the License Agreement and so
on and so forth so you once you do
multiple enters it will bring you to the
next step
all right so now here again they say do
you accept the terms you just say yes
and then press ENTER and here it will
ask you a couple of questions and pretty
much you need to just go for the default
version press ENTER to confirm you just
say press ENTER and this is primarily
when it will pretty much start the
installation process of anaconda this
might take a little while depending
again on your internet speed so you need
to have some patience
we will also probably come back once
this installation is done or if I if it
asks for any further questions
all right so
here you'll get again one more question
the use to fish the Installer to pray
free pen so you just say yes for this
question and keep going now the last
question I think we are pretty much at
the end and that is about Microsoft we
assess I guess yeah we ask or so for
this you can just say no because we will
not be using this and that's it you're
done so this is completion of
installation of anaconda so it's always
a good idea to exit and start afresh
terminal okay so
so we are done with the installation of
anaconda the next step is to create a
virtual environment with Python 3.4 so
for that this is the command
kondeh create - n and this is the name
of your virtual environment you can give
any name but for easy reference I have
given a stencil floor and we have to
specify the Python version as I
mentioned earlier we will be using the
combination of Python 3.4 and tensorflow
1.5 now this is not the latest version
Python has probably three point six at
this point at the time of creation of
this video and even tensorflow probably
as the latest version as one point seven
but then these combinations sometimes
may not work and I found that after
several trials and errors three point
four with one point five seems to be
most reliable line that's the reason I
have chosen this I would recommend you
to try it with this first if you are a
big No and later on maybe you can try
out other permutations and combinations
all right one step I just wanted to show
you is before we do the installation or
creation of the virtual environment if
you want to just clarify or confirm
whether anaconda has been installed or
not you can run what is known as
anaconda navigator so you just say
anaconda navigator ok we need to edit
this part hold on one second I guess it
is
all right so you see here when you start
anaconda navigator this anaconda
navigator will open up that is the
indication that anaconda has been
installed properly well that's just a
quick check and you don't have to do
anything just you can go back and close
it once this comes up and then in the
meanwhile let me just open one more
terminal for the creation of the virtual
environment and yeah so this is your
anaconda navigator and you can just say
okay don't show me just say okay and
then you can close this you can save
file then do a file exit or click on the
close button or so we will exit from
here we have we will use this for our
next steps alright so what we have to do
now is type in this piece of code or
this command
reason copy-paste just not working so
it's a small command such issue so we
say Conda
and we say create so this is the command
for creating a new environment
/ - n and then we give the name of the
environment so we will we can give any
name for convenience I'm just calling it
tensorflow
but you can actually name it anything
and then we need to specify with the
which version of Python so we say trip
fight them and then that is equal 3.4 ok
so it will create an environment this
fellow take a little boy little ask your
question just say yes and then done so
this is just a warning you can simply
ignore that and for the question that it
asks you just say yes and I think you
should be good
all right so it says do you want to
proceed you say yes and enter
this will again take a little bit little
time so we will probably move forward
and then come back once this is done
all right so the environment has been
created now it's always a good idea to
whenever some of these steps get over or
each step gets over you just exit the
terminal and start afresh with a new
terminal for some reason sometimes it
causes problem if you continue so I
found that it is our safe practice tool
each time exit the terminal and start
afresh now that we have an environment
created we can by the name tensorflow
you can enter that environment by
calling the command source activate
tensile floor the name whatever name you
have given so you'll see here once you
do that you will get this the name of
the environment will be shown here so it
is like your own again a special
environment within within the system and
from here onwards you can do other stuff
like actually installing tensorflow and
so on and you will see that it has
installed Python 3 here so three point
four right so it is installed that's
what we during creation of this
environment we want it by three point
four so that is what it is showing but
we are not yet done so we need to still
install tensorflow so in this
environment you need to run a command
which will actually install the correct
combination of tensorflow now this is as
you can see it's a slightly complicated
command with install - - ignore it so
what we can do is from within here we
can go and go to tensorflow install page
and there is a sample code there you can
pick up from there so that you don't
have to type in so much so we say it
ends a flow tensor flow torque and I'll
also open our probably in notepad here
so that we can construct that come on
and go here
they say one two if you come for the
town they by the way we are doing CPU
installation I think that is clear you
know there is the possibility to do GPU
as well we will probably create a
separate video for that and if we go
here yeah so again you probably if you
followed the entire document out here it
may still not work so I do not recommend
that for now at least for beginners but
just to copy this command because this
is a fairly complicated command so this
is much easier to copy it from here
that's the reason on this page and we
modify it according to yes ok copy and
don't do it directly here because that
is probably not yet the right come on
let us go and create add page document
I'll just say TF dot txt okay this is
just a temporary file what we need to do
here is we need to adjust this command
to suit the versions that we are
installing here so let me just explain
what it is what you need to do so first
thing you can get rid of this one yes
okay now here these parts you can simply
ignore here you need to go and change it
to version 1.5 and I think we are good
with that okay so the CP 3 4 indicates
your Python 3.4 so later on when you're
trying to experiment and if you want to
do other combinations of tensorflow and
python version then you can change this
for example you can change this to 3-6
both these places you need to change
this to 3-6 if you are using with python
3.6 and similarly if you want the latest
version which is of tensorflow which is
one point seven you need to change this
to 1 point 7 and so on but at this point
to start with if you are a beginner I
would recommend that you stick to the
stencil flow 1.5 with Python 3.4 this is
tried and tested and it works ok just a
word of caution that just by changing
these versions to it the whole thing
will not work there may be other places
where you may have to some of the steps
may change so just a word of caution
that just by changing this if you want
to try out with a different version some
of the steps may also change so you
don't think that just by changing this
this one particular command you will be
fine okay so that's been my experience
so to start with I would recommend use
this particular combination alright so
it looks good or tensorflow 1.5 and let
me just reconfirm with my notes and I
think it looks good so this is install
ignore 1.5 CP 3 for CP 3 4 and so on ok
ok let's hit enter it started the
process again this might take a little
while so we will pause the recording and
then get back when the installation is
done ok so looks like this installation
is done and as always let us exit and
then come back now you are currently in
the environment virtual environment and
it's a good practice before you exit out
of the terminal to come on out of the
virtual environment so just like you did
source activate you need to do source
deactivate and the name denser flow ok
you will come back to the original
command prompt and then from here you
can do an exit now we need to validate
whether the 10th of law installation has
gone through properly or not so the way
to validate is to first start python and
then import tenth of your library see if
it imports without error so that's the
best way to validate so we'll open a
terminal and whenever you want to get
into
environment this is how you have to do
come to an environment and then say
source and obviously you can also use
existing so source activate tensile flow
okay so we do this and you need to run
Python from here remember you should say
Python three because you have installed
53.4 now here when you say import
tensorflow SDF when you get back a
prompt like this without any errors that
means tensorflow installation has been
successful if tensorflow was not
installed properly you will get an error
saying ten supply is not available or
module doesn't exist or something like
that so ten super insulation is done but
now we will go through the process of
installing jupiter notebook so that you
can do your development so let me just
exit and in order to install your cube
meter notebook which is your debt which
is going to be your development
environment we will first install
ipython using corner so corner install
ipython and then pip install Jupiter so
let's first do the I button Condor
install Python I mean it will ask you a
question saying these are the components
do you want to install you just say yes
all right you say yes once again it'll
take a little while so we might pause
the recording and come back once it is
done
great so they did not take much time
anyways so we will as usual we will exit
which is source deactivate tensorflow
exit and then we will start a fresh
terminal in order to install Jupiter now
in some places they must say install
Jupiter using fig tree but in my
experience it did not work with v3 and
that's the reason we will use PIP
however just keep in mind you need to
first go to the environment so source
activate tensorflow and you need to use
this command which is PIP installed
Jupiter usually when you are on Python 3
you use hip 3 but as I said it did not
work so in my experience it works with
the Installer not the tree so pip
install Jupiter I hope you already
noticed that it is Ju py ter and not j
bi
so again it's probably taking a little
while we will pause the recording and
come back once it is done okay so
Jupiter installation is also done once
again you need to say good idea not you
need to but it's a good idea to come out
of this terminal session and then start
afresh
so we exit we have a fresh terminal
already available here and we go once
again go to tensorflow
and we say Jupiter no that's how you
start your Jupiter notebook
so this looks good now only thing is
since we are running for the first time
what you need to do is if you come back
do your command prompt it will show you
that if you are running it for the first
time it will say that you need to copy
paste this link so you you can just for
the first time only once you need to do
this copy this and paste it in your
browser and remember this is only the
first time when you're running Jupiter
you need to do this subsequently you
don't have to it will automatically open
up alright so now that we have Jupiter
installed and it starts up we need to
test whether transfer is working fine or
not and in order to do that you can
create a new notebook and you say import
tensorflow yes shift-enter
if everything is fine dancefloor is
installed properly you don't get any
errors and then it works fine this is an
indication that tensorflow got installed
successfully and that's about it so
that's all about installing tensorflow
with Python 3.4 so remember this is
installation of tensorflow 1.5 with
Python 3.4 on Ubuntu and once again in
case you have a Windows system in fact I
have also done it on a Windows system
you can use VirtualBox to create a
virtual environment
ubuntu environment and then follow these
steps and there are tons of videos to
create VirtualBox and that's the reason
we have not included those steps in this
and if there are any comments there are
better ways to do this please
mention it in the comment section below
or if you need any further help just
mention it and with your email we will
respond to you thank you very much and
have a great day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here